Russell Brand has been an actor a
comedian a podcast host for decades all
of a sudden he's one of the most
forceful voices for the truth in the
English-speaking world
he's also a deeply interesting person
with a lot of insights about God
amazingly Russell Brand we sat down with
him for a long conversation a brand new
episode Tucker Carlson today here's a
small part of it
[Music]
as much as I might enjoy the feeling of
privilege and luxury and I'm certainly
making no claims to be an ascetic I
remember what reality is I remember that
my Wellness is contingent upon spiritual
connection upon certain values and
principles and they I am sorry to admit
involves sacrifice and self-scrutiny
about my own conduct and behavior which
is often we often fall short and I'm
working on improving myself I continue
to work on improving myself so when I
sort of hear morality sort of as bombast
or when I hear rhetoric divorce from
compassion it makes me feel uneasy so
I've been blessed with a very practical
spirituality like many desperate people
I need spirituality I need God or I
cannot COPE in this world I need to
believe in the best in people I need to
believe that there are new alliances
possible new ways of us communicating
because I see atrophying and corrupt
systems delivering and get more misery
to people and I think it's increasingly
necessary that we find new ways of
framing the conversation and looking
into our hearts when we're speaking are
we being kind are we being loving are we
being the best that we can be on whose
behalf are we speaking and what is my
intention moment to moment am I doing
this for self-glorification am I doing
this because I have obligations to
rumble the platform I'm on or am I doing
this because I genuinely believe that a
better world is possible and that world
is born individually within each of us
moment to moment and it's possible to
change I genuinely believe in change and
I'm not in my court a misanthrope I
don't believe that we need systems of
condemnation I don't believe that if
people aren't heavily policed and
heavily controlled they'll behave badly
I believe that we can self-organize I
believe I'm optimistic about your
country and I'm optimistic about mine
and I'm optimistic about the world but I
think the price of that optimism is a
degree of reason and an acceptance that
many people see the world very very
differently at this time and we're going
to have to allow one another some
distance to be who we are whether that's
individually or community unally and
these are the areas that interest me and
these are the things that have always
interested me the fact was I just didn't
have enough self-discipline to resist
the Allure of stardom and I fell face
first into the glitter and I'm only just
pulling myself out now but once I
stopped drinking and taking drugs it
became clear that there was a lot more
on offer the ability to in fact as they
say recovery the term recovery is
undergirded by the idea that we recover
the person we're intended to be and this
idea of intention I think is rather
beautiful because when you live in a
nihilistic post-rationalistic
materialistic world where there can be
no Telos where there can be no glory
where there can't be no meaning none of
us are meant to be anything but the idea
that there might be a purpose for you
that there might be something that you
can become this um I I found this I I
did very engaging and very comforting
and I've got to be honest it also
engaged the raw more egoic and
narcissistic aspects of me that I could
achieve something in my life but as time
has gone on there's been there's an
ongoing tension between those things
individual achievement and a sort of an
ongoing desire for recognition applaud
is but a a deeper understanding that
there is something valuable here on
offer that we can achieve something and
it's actually sort of quite humble
irritatingly isn't it like that it's
mostly about helping people directly my
world view is formed by spiritual
principles rather than political spin
principles but my values are derived
from quite simple ideas around kindness
Community acceptance gratitude and I'm
making no claim to practice these
principles anything like perfectly but
at least I know what I'm aspiring to and
I know that my spirituality is about my
conduct and how I behave rather than
telling other people how they should
behave
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight